[Musique]
ap
bonjour mesdames messieurs
je suis heureux d'accueillir aujourd'hui
à paris le président du tadjikistan
monsieur emomali rahmon en visite
officielle en france j'avais déjà eu ce
monsieur le président l'honneur et la
joie de vous accueillir à paris en
novembre 2019
et je garde un excellent souvenir de l'
échange que nous avions alors eu l'année
l'autre
la france et le tadjikistan célébreront
bientôt les 30 ans de relations
diplomatiques
marqué par la confiance et un dialogue
toujours plus étroit sur les questions
de sécurité mais aussi de coopération
économique et culturelle
cette visite est d'ailleurs marquée à
cet égard par la première exposition
consacrée au patrimoine archéologique du
tadjikistan intitulé tadjikistan au pays
des fleuves d'or et nous irons inauguré
tout à l'heure avec monsieur le
président cette magnifique exposition au
musée national des arts asiatiques le
musée guimet
cette exposition montre que le
tadjikistan est un carrefour de
civilisation plurimillénaire
bercé par l' influence du monde perse de
la grèce antique du bouddhisme dans
l'inventivité et la créativité reflètent
la richesse et la diversité de toutes
ses origines elle consacre aussi
l'aboutissement d'un travail collectif
de plusieurs décennies entre eux les
archéologues
les conservateurs tadjik des français
c'est avec fierté que je salue l'oeuvre
commune de nos deux pays à cet égard
elle offre aussi l'occasion d'attirer
l'attention du public sur ce patrimoine
commun de l'humanité qu'il est de notre
responsabilité à tous de préserver pour
les générations futures
nous allons maintenant nous entretenir
avec le président de nos relations
bilatérales et de la situation en asie
centrale
le tadjikistan à une longue frontière
avec l'afghanistan et partage avec la
france un grand nombre de préoccupations
il ya plusieurs semaines nous avions eu
l'occasion de nous entretenir
téléphoniquement et de pouvoir
d'ailleurs le constater
cette visite officielle est aussi
l'occasion de nourrir notre dialogue sur
la sécurité régionale en cette période
d'incertitude nous ferons le point avec
le président sur l'aide que la france
peut apporter au tadjikistan pour
stabiliser la situation et la
contribution utile que nous pouvons
apporter à toute la région mais je veux
d'ores et déjà salué le rôle qui est le
vôtre l'engagement qui est le vôtre et
l'exigence qui est la vôtre pour que les
changements dans la région soit facteur
de stabilité au maximum et qu'il n'y ait
aucune compromission avec les groupes
terroristes ni avec les valeurs que nous
défendons en particulier la dignité des
femmes
je les dis nous souhaitons également
renforcer nos relations économiques et
l'occasion de la visite du président
était également une feuille de route
pour le développement de la coopération
entre le tadjikistan à la france sur les
cinq prochaines années elle sera signée
je m'en félicite merci encore président
d'être là aujourd'hui à paris
je vous sais de la parole
moi je fais suivre
[Musique]
les jours
à part de mon profond respect
mesdames messieurs bonjour à toutes et à
tous je souhaitais débuter ce compte
rendu du conseil des ministres en
rendant hommage à hubert germain le
dernier des 1038 compagnons de la
libération décédé hier sa disparition
nous rappelle notre devoir collectif de
faire vivre la mémoire de cette période
de tous ceux qui ont eu le courage de
s'opposer au maréchal pétain et dont
l'engagement à sauver notre liberté
notre pays et notre honneur le président
de la république a fait part en
ouverture de ce conseil des ministres de
ses pensées affectueuses et respectueuse
à l'endroit du maire germain il a
rappelé que notre pays lui doit beaucoup
la nation rendra hommage à hubert
germain vendredi aux invalides puis le
11 novembre au mont valérien je veux
évidemment aussi avoir une pensée pour
les proches des frères d'armes du
maréchal des logis adrien chélin disparu
au mali dans une opération de
maintenance
pour ce qui est du conseil des ministres
nous avons débuté par un texte portant
sur notre vigilance constante et
permanente que nous impose l'épidémie de
kobe de 19 alors que l'hiver approche et
que l'épidémie n'est pas encore derrière
nous le premier ministre a présenté un
projet de loi portant diverses
dispositions de vigilance sanitaire
cette vigilance nous l'assumons nous
assumons de protéger le pays comme
depuis le premier jour il ya encore plus
de 4000 cas par jour en moyenne dans
notre pays et la situation ne s'améliore
plus depuis quelques jours il ya encore
18 départements où le taux d'incidence
dépasse le seuil d alerte de 50 et dans
certains territoires le nombre de cases
semble reprendre légèrement il ya encore
dans les outre-mer et notamment en
guyane des situations dramatiques qui
requiert une mobilisation importante de
renforce d'hospitaliers il ya encore
dans le monde de nombreux pays où le
virus circule très activement il ya
encore nous le savons un risque non
négligeable de reprise épidémique
l'hiver est propice à ce type de reprise
de nouveaux variants nous l'avons vécu
peuvent apparaître et un échappement
immunitaire n'est pas à exclure nous
voyons bien aux antilles ce qu'une
faible immunité peut produire comme
dégâts alors oui nous devons rester
vigilants jusqu'à l'été prochain nous
devons garder à notre disposition des
mesures de freinage qui ont prouvé toute
leur efficacité pour prévenir des
flambées épidémiques et qui ont sauvé
des dizaines de milliers de vies si la
plupart ne sont aujourd'hui plus en
vigueur nous devons pouvoir les activer
à tout moment si c'est nécessaire sans
perdre de temps nous devons exclure
aucun scénario y compris celui d'une
reprise active de la circulation virale
dans notre pays cette épidémie nous a
appris à ne jamais rien exclure par
principe nous assumons notre refus d'un
désarmement sanitaire qui serait plus
que précipiter face à une épidémie qui
nous a tant de fois surpris et qui
surtout n'est pas fini pour toutes ces
raisons nous sommes depuis le 2 juin
dernier entré dans un régime de sortie
de crise sanitaire qui laisse à notre
disposition l'ensemble des mesures de
freinage qui peuvent s'avérer
nécessaires pour protéger les français
et le texte que nous avons examiné ce
matin prolonge ses possibilités jusqu'au
31 juillet 2022 j'ai entendu ces
derniers jours de nouveaux de nombreux
professionnels de l'indignation s'agiter
j'entends beaucoup de fantasmes et des
propos malveillants souvent fondées sur
des informations largement erronée ou
déformés j'entends aussi quelques
inquiétudes sincère souvent nourri par
le peu de scrupules de ceux qui ont fait
de l'épidémie leur fonds de commerce je
vais donc vous dire ce que prévoit ce
texte est ce que ne prévoit pas ce texte
ce que prévoit ce texte c'est d'abord
que jusqu'au 31 juillet nous pourrons si
et seulement si c'est nécessaire
encadrer l'activité des établissements
recevant du public exigé le pass
sanitaire ce que prévoit à ce texte
c'est que jusqu'au 31 juillet si et
seulement si la situation sanitaire
s'aggravait brutalement nous pourrons
prendre des décrets déclarant l'état
d'urgence sanitaire sur tout ou partie
du territoire pour une durée limitée à
30 jours délai au delà duquel une loi
devra revoter cet état d'urgence nous
permet de prendre des mesures de
confinement de couvre-feu dont l'exemple
antillais nous a encore récemment
rappelé l'efficacité pour freiner des
reprises dévastatrice ce que prévoit ce
texte c'est aussi un renforcement de la
lutte contre la fraude au pass sanitaire
ce que prévoit ce texte ce sont des
mesures d'accompagnement économique
permettant de faire face en tant que de
besoin aux conséquences de la crise
ce que prévoit ce texte c'est quand en
guyane où le taux d'incidence et la
tension hospitalière reste
particulièrement élevée l'état d'urgence
sanitaire en vigueur sera prolongé
jusqu'à la fin de l'année maintenant je
vais vous dire ce que ne prévoit pas ce
texte la distinction tient en une phrase
il ne faut pas confondre les mesures
possibles avec les mesures appliquées et
en l'espèce pour l'immense majorité des
français nous sommes au plus faible
niveau de restriction depuis 18 mois ce
texte ne prévoit pas l'état d'urgence
éternel ils retardent le moment où cet
outil disparaîtra définitivement de
notre panoplie juridique mais pour
autant le retour de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire n'être absolument pas à
l'ordre du jour ce texte ne prévoit pas
le pass sanitaires à vie comme nous
l'avons toujours dit à la seconde où il
ne sera plus nécessaire pour contrôler
l'épidémie nous serons ravis de le
retirer nous n'avons je le dis chaque
semaine aucun fétichisme du qr codes
prolonger la possibilité de recourir aux
passes ce n'est pas prolonger son
existence soyons clairs vous l'avez vu
ces dernières semaines
dès que nous pouvons lever une
contrainte comme le masque à l'école par
exemple nous le faisons sans attendre et
évidemment nous espérons que si la
situation reste dans une dynamique
d'amélioration nous pourrons adapter le
pass sanitaire dès les prochaines
semaines voire même le suspendre
complètement
ce texte c'est la garantie de notre
réactivité en cas de reprise épidémique
sans lui nous pourrions nous retrouver
désarmés face à un variant contagieux et
devoir attendre un mois de débat
parlementaire avant d'y répondre
personne ne l'accepterai grâce à ce
texte donc nous pourrons prendre les
mesures nécessaires toutes les mesures
nécessaires mais seulement celles qui
seront nécessaires nous garderons
toujours à l'esprit cette priorité
apporter à tout instant une réponse
proportionnée et efficace allez solution
de l'épidémie
néanmoins il convient de le rappeler le
reflux épidémique est certes très nette
même si la situation sanitaire je le
disais ne s'améliorent plus ne semble
plus améliorée depuis quelques jours le
nombre de cas les admissions
hospitalières et la tension en soins
critiques diminue tous de plus de 10% en
une semaine un seul département de la
métropole la lozère affiche encore un
taux d'incidence supérieur à 100 dans
les antilles l'embellie se poursuit et
en guyane une décrue épidémique semble
s'amorcer même si la situation reste
très tendue à la réunion nous avons mis
fin ce matin en conseil des ministres
par un décret qui a été adoptée à l'état
d'urgence sanitaire dès ce vendredi
cette décision actes l'amélioration
nette et durable de la situation
sanitaire de l'île autre bonne nouvelle
près de 90% des français éligibles ont
reçu au moins une dose du vaccin qui
l'eût cru il y a un an et selon une
étude française publiée lundi portant
sur 22 millions de personnes nous avons
eu une nouvelle confirmation que ce
vaccin protège à 90% des formes graves
jusqu'à cinq mois après la deuxième dose
cette donnée ne doit pas pour autant
faire oublier l'importance des rappels
et comme je lé fais à chaque compte
rendu du conseil des ministres devant
vous depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines je veux évidemment appelé les
français qui sont éligibles au rappel
vaccinal à se faire vacciner c'est à
dire les français âgés de plus de 65 ans
ou qui ont une fragilité qui les expose
très fortement à la maladie de qu'ovide
19 aujourd'hui 5 millions environ de
français sont éligibles correspondant à
ces catégories et un million et demi
seulement ont déjà eu recours au rappel
vaccinal je rappelle que le rappel
vaccinal vient également d'être ouverts
pour les personnels soignants vous
l'aurez compris la confiance n'exclut
pas la prudence et nous restons prêts à
réagir au moindre signal d'alerté
l'actualité de cette semaine c'est aussi
la présentation de france 2030 par le
président de la république hier alors
que beaucoup regardent en arrière et
fonde la nostalgie le fondement de leur
idéologie que d'autres ne regarde que
les débats d'appareils nous assumons de
regarder devant et nous assumons de
donner aux français un horizon de
conquête d'innovation et de progrès
collectifs face aux prophètes du déclin
et du repli je ne reviendrai pas ici sur
le détail des mesures mais je voudrais
simplement souligner quelques grandes
lignes de notre ambition car après avoir
réussi la reprise par la relance nous
voulons désormais réussir la conquête
par l'investissement car il ne s'agit
pas simplement de retrouver le taux de
croissance ou le niveau d'emploi que
nous connaissions avant la crise du
coffee de 19 mais bien d'aller beaucoup
plus loin france 2030 répond aux grands
défis de notre temps la reconquête
industrielle la souveraineté
l'indépendance le changement climatique
et le défi démographique il remet au
coeur de notre ambition ce continuum
industrie innovation et recherche qui
est le moteur de toutes les grandes
découvertes il nous fixent des objectifs
dits conquête dix projets collectifs qui
amélioreront concrètement notre vie et
placeront la france à la tête de
l'innovation ainsi nous allons investir
pour assurer notre souveraineté
énergétique et pour développer un
nucléaire plus propre et plus durable
nous allons investir pour devenir les
leaders mondiaux de l'hydrogène vert
nous allons investir pour produire 2
millions de véhicules hybrides et pour
produire le premier avion bas carbone
nous allons investir pour une
alimentation plus saine nous allons
investir pour produire plus de
médicaments innovants nous allons
investir pour la culture nous allons
investir pour le spatial et nous allons
investir pour les fonds marins nous
allons vous l'aurez compris investir
massivement pour l'avenir de la france
et des français par ces projets par
cette ambition nous allons refaire de la
france une nation fière conquérante et
indépendante dans une europe forte car
oui c'est un projet économique mais
c'est aussi je le crois profondément
un projet de cohésion nationale ce que
nous voulons c'est rassembler les
français autour d'une vision de conquête
et dans mission commune enfin à quelques
jours de la journée mondiale du refus de
la misère nous avons effectué en conseil
des ministres un point sur la stratégie
pour voter et plus globalement sur
l'action menée par le ministère des
solidarités et de la santé de l'ensemble
du gouvernement pour réduire la pauvreté
je tiens à le dire ce quinquennat aura
été marquée par une ambition sociale
inédite et ininterrompue dans ce
quinquennat nous avons agi directement
pour les revenus des plus précaires avec
des revalorisations de l'allocation
adulte handicapé et du minimum
vieillesse avec la hausse du chèque
énergie mais aussi je ne reviens pas
dessus avec un effort inédit en faveur
des bas salaires il ya par exemple eu 1
3 million de foyers bénéficiaires de la
hausse de la prime d'activité durant la
crise sanitaire nous avons déployé un
véritable bouclier social sans précédent
en octroyant à deux reprises d aide
exceptionnelle de solidarité en
revalorisant l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire et en préservant massivement
les revenus des travailleurs français
mais ce quinquennat a également été
marquée par une révolution des
politiques sociales notre choix de nous
attaquer aux inégalités de destin
partout où elle se forme a constitué le
fil rouge de notre action dans
l'ensemble des domaines nous avons donc
déployer une politique ambitieuse
inédite et inter ministériel pour
réduire fortement la pauvreté en
s'attaquant à ses racines et en
promouvant l'activité c'est pour
combattre l'assignation à résidence que
nous avons dédoubler les classes de
grande section maternelle de cp et de
ce1 pour 330 mille élèves chaque année
mis en place les vacances à prenantes
pour quatre cent mille enfants et mener
un effort inédit pour le nombre et la
qualité la mixité des places en crèche
c'est pour réduire la pauvreté que nous
avons créé la complémentaire santé
solidaire réduit à zéro le reste à
charge des lunettes prothèses auditives
et couronne dentaire et rembourser les
consultations de psychologues c'est pour
réduire la pauvreté que nous avons
fortement augmenté le budget de l'aide
alimentaire développer les petits
déjeuners gratuits en zone prioritaire
pour trois cent mille élèves ainsi que 2
5 millions de repas un euro à la cantine
scolaire c'est pour réduire la pauvreté
que nous avons simplifié les démarches
administratives et automatisée des
ouvertures de droits
c'est pour réduire la pauvreté que nous
avons augmenté de 50% le budget du
logement déployer déployer le plan
logement d'abord atteint un nombre
record de 200 mille places d'hébergement
sans gestion au thermomètre est mis en
place des dispositifs spécifiques pour
protéger les femmes les associations le
reconnaisse l'état mène un effort
important et inédit en la matière c'est
pour réduire la pauvreté et combattre la
précarité que nous avons agi pour le
retour à l'emploi en instaurant
l'obligation de formation des 16-18 ans
en améliorant l'accompagnement des
bénéficiaires du rsa et en déployant
cent mille solutions supplémentaires
pour l'insertion par l'activité
économique
mais nous le savons aussi la pauvreté
frappe particulièrement certains publics
précaires nous avons donc agi de manière
ciblée en faveur des enfants et de leurs
familles notamment les familles
monoparentales pour aider les familles
et casser le cycle de la reproduction de
la pauvreté pour les mères isolées nous
avons augmenté le complément mode de
garde de 30% et déployer un service
protecteur des pensions alimentaires je
vous rappelle je vous le présentait la
semaine dernière avec le plfss pour 2022
nous automatise on est généralisons
l'intermédiation des pensions
alimentaires pour les femmes pour les
enfants sortant de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance nous avons lutté avec
acharnement entre les sorties sèches à
18 ans et trois sortants sur quatre sont
désormais prises en charge évidemment il
reste de très grandes difficultés dans
notre pays évidemment que de très
nombreux français sont dans la précarité
souffre mais nous commençons à voir des
résultats grâce à cette ambition et à
cette mobilisation massive le revenu
médian a augmenté de 2,6 pour cent
quatre-vingt mille personnes sont
sorties de la pauvreté malgré la crise
et ce taux de pauvreté recule 12 fois
plus que la moyenne pour les familles
monoparentales
par ailleurs 280000 sans domicile fixe
ont pu accéder au logement depuis le
début de cette mobilisation mesdames et
messieurs ce conseil des ministres a été
également l'occasion d'adopter plusieurs
textes sur lesquels je reviens
brièvement d'abord sur proposition du
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères un projet de loi autorisant
la ati fication de la création de
l'organisation internationale pour les
aides à la navigation maritime
ce nouvel organisme ne viendra renforcer
la sécurité et l'efficacité de l'action
intergouvernementale dans ce domaine
ensuite jean yves le drian a présenté un
deuxième projet de loi ratifiant
l'accord entre la france et le
tadjikistan sur les services aériens ce
texte apportera la sécurité juridique
nécessaire aux transporteurs et témoigne
de notre proximité avec le tadjikistan
en matière d'aviation civile venait
ensuite sur proposition de la ministre
de la culture un projet de loi ratifiant
une ordonnance de transposition d'une
directive européenne sur le droit
d'auteur et les droits voisins cette
ordonnance vise à faciliter
l'acquisition des droits transfrontalier
de diffusion tout en garantissant une
juste rémunération aux créateurs et aux
titulaires de droits c'est une avancée
majeure une nouvelle avancée majeure
pour défendre notre exception culturelle
et réguler les grandes plateformes
la ministre de la transition écologique
a présenté une ordonnance réformant
l'évaluation des biotechnologies le but
de ce texte est simple mieux encadrer le
recours aux ogm et mieux assurer leur
traçabilité notamment en permettant
d'identifier les exploitations sur
lesquels se sont déjà déroulées des
utilisations d' ogm ce texte confie
également à l' agence nationale de
sécurité sanitaire de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail la
responsabilité d'évaluer les risques
d'utilisation de biotechnologie enfin la
ministre de la mer a présenté une
ordonnance encadrant les conditions de
navigation des navires autonome et des
drones maritime cette ordonnance fait de
la france un des premiers états à
légiférer sur ce secteur émergent de
navigation de manière à lever les
obstacles et à maintenir un haut niveau
de sécurité et de préservation de
l'environnement voilà mesdames messieurs
ce que je pourrais vous dire sur ce
conseil des ministres et je me tiens
désormais à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions
lors de ce conseil des ministres le
président de la république at il évoqué
la hausse préoccupante du prix des
carburants ces derniers temps le
gouvernement va-t-il agir et oui si oui
quand et comment sur ces prêts du
carburant à l'instar du bouclier
tarifaire instaurait concernant le prix
du gaz et d'électricité récemment merci
beaucoup oui président de la république
avait l'occasion de revenir sur ce sujet
est d'abord de rappeler que depuis
plusieurs semaines nous avons montré que
le gouvernement évidemment étaient au
rendez-vous pour protéger les français
face aux hausses des prix de l'énergie
dont je rappelle qu'elles sont
immédiatement lié à la reprise
économique mondiale très forte à la
demande très forte d'énergie pour les
mobilités pour l'industrie notamment qui
entraîne une hausse des prix nous avons
pris des mesures sur le prix du gaz pour
qu'il n'y ait pas les augmentations
prévues d'ici à la fin de l'année de
l'ordre de 30 à 40 % du prix du gaz le
prix du gaz a été gelé parce que nous
avons pris des mesures nous avons pris
des mesures par anticipation sur la
question du prix de l'électricité vous
savez que certaines estimations et la
plupart des estimations estimait une
hausse à prévoir du prix d'électricité
de l'ordre de 12 % au mois de janvier
nous avons pris des mesures en avance de
phase pour contraindre évidemment cette
cause qui sera limité au maximum à 4 %
c'est-à-dire trois fois moins que la
hausse qui serait intervenue si nous ne
prenons pas ces mesures qui sont des
mesures de baisse de fiscalité il y a
également la mesures que nous avons
prises de renforcement du chèque énergie
puisque l'ensemble des foyers les
millions de foyers bénéficiaires du
chèque énergie qui le perçoivent
habituellement au mois d'avril pour un
montant moyen de 150 euros mais qui peut
aller jusqu'à près de 300 400 euros
recevront un chèque exceptionnelle de
100 euros d'ici à la fin de l'année il
ya une augmentation on le voit du prix
du carburant il y à un certain nombre de
français beaucoup de français qui
prennent tous les jours leur voiture
pour aller travailler parfois font
beaucoup de routes qui ont donc une
dépenses incompressibles de carburant et
ce sont souvent des français d'ailleurs
qui travaillent dur pour une
rémunération un salaire qui ne leur
permet pas toujours de boucler leurs
fins de mois et c'est aussi pour ça que
depuis le début de ce quinquennat nous a
agi pour augmenter la rémunération du
travail et notamment de ceux qui ont du
mal à boucler leurs fins de mois alors
même qu'ils travaillent augmentation de
la prime d'activité baisse des
cotisations salariales
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires tout cela permettant
pour une personne qui travaille au smic
d'avoir en aide un treizième et un quasi
14e mans je rappelle également les
mesures de baisse de l'impôt sur le
revenu pour les premières tranches je
rappelle également la mise en place de
la prime macron qui a été versée à
plusieurs millions de français cette
action qui a été
résolu depuis 2010 est qu'elles étaient
progressivement amplifiée au cours du
quinquennat elle vise précisément à
faire en sorte que nos concitoyens qui
travaillent qui travaille dur et qui ont
du mal à boucler leurs fins de mois tu
sois davantage soutenus et accompagnés
pour leur travail il ya cette hausse des
prix du carburant dont le fmi et un
certain nombre d'experts disait encore
hier qu'elle devrait durer jusqu'à la
fin du premier trimestre probablement
avant de diminuer donc la question c'est
comment est-ce qu'on accompagne les
français pendant cette période qui est
une période difficile sur ce sujet là
elle président de la république l'a
redit ce matin en conseil des ministres
nous travaillons à des mesures de
protection qui pourraient être prises
pour accompagner les français dans ces
moments difficiles il y à des travaux
qui sont en cours je ne peux pas vous
faire d'annonce aujourd'hui mais ce que
je peux vous dire que ce sont des
travaux qui sont nourris
bonjour monsieur ministre s'amuse taxi
pour canal+ senio une question
concernant la crise sanitaire ce
prolongement possible de l'état
d'urgence a été avare en jambes et de
fait l'élection présidentielle on le
sait c'est un texte et vous l'avez
rappelé qui va laisser au gouvernement
une très large manoeuvre sur les
contraintes qui peuvent être imposées
aux français où vous l'avez dit le
couvre-feu les mesures de confinement
que répondez-vous aux oppositions qui
considère que ce moment justement de
l'élection de présidentielle doit être
sanctuarisé que ce moment ce temps de
démocratie ne doit pas être soumis à
quelques pressions que ce soit donc
notamment de cette possible état
d'urgence sanitaire qui reviendra merci
il y aura un débat au parlement sur ce
sujet là notamment avec les oppositions
moi ce que je constate d'abord c'est que
depuis début de cette crise les
oppositions ont toujours prouvé beaucoup
cherché matière à critiquer à s'opposer
au gouvernement et aux décisions que
nous prenons on a fermé les écoles nous
ont dit qu'il fallait laisser ouvertes
quand on les a ouvertes nous ont dit
qu'il fallait laisser fermer quand on a
confiné ils ont dit qu'il fallait pas le
faire et quand on a décidé de ne pas
confiné ils nous ont expliqué qu'il
aurait fallu confiné quand on a mis en
place le pass sanitaires un certain
nombre se sont opposés au passé annie
terre d'autres n'ont pas franchement
soutenu le gouvernement et je pourrais
donner d'autres exemples sur la
vaccination aujourd'hui au moment où le
gouvernement présente un texte de
gestion de la crise sanitaire de
vigilance sanitaire il est une
opposition d opposition ne me surprend
pas ensuite je veux rappeler et que
l'état d'urgence sanitaire la
possibilité de décréter l'état d'urgence
sanitaire a été je crois prolonger
d'ores et déjà à deux reprises qu'à
chaque fois qu'il a été prolongée il a
été de l'ordre de 10 mois donc ceux qui
disent que c'est une durée de
prolongation qui est anormal par rapport
aux décisions qui ont pu être prises
auparavant c'est factuellement faux
puisque dès lors que lorsque nous avons
prolongé l'état d'urgence sanitaire ou
la possibilité d'y recourir c'était à
chaque fois pour une période de 10 mois
ou 10 mois et demi on est dans ces eaux
là aujourd'hui avec la décision qui a
été prise en tout cas ce qui est proposé
dans le texte de loi qui sera évidemment
discuté par le parlement ensuite ce que
je dis est ce que je rappelle je les
fais à l'occasion de mon propos
liminaire c'est qu'il ne s'agit pas de
dire que l'on va prolonger jusqu'en
juillet prochain les mesures qui
s'appliquent aujourd'hui dans le
quotidien des français je crois qu'on a
montré depuis le début de cette crise
qu'à chaque fois qu'on pouvait réduire
les mesures de contraintes qui
s'imposent aux français on le faisait on
l'a fait à chacune des vagues de cette
épidémie
première vague on a tous fermés le monde
entier découvrait ce virus deuxième
vague on a pu maintenir nos écoles
ouvertes troisième vague on a pu prendre
des mesures qui n'était pas un
confinement mais qui poussait au
contraire les français à rester dehors
plutôt que dans des lieux clos quatrième
vague on a pu laisser ouvert nos
restaurants nos barnaud théâtre nô
cinéma à ce qu'on bénéficier du pass
sanitaires à chaque fois on le peut
parce qu'on progresse aussi dans la
connaissance qu'on a du virus parce
qu'on a la vaccination évidemment qui
est un renfort colossal évidemment qu'on
choisit le niveau le plus faible
possible de contraintes sanitaires et
vous avez bien vu j'en parlais tout à
l'heure que y compris s'agissant du
masque dès lors qu'on peut lever et on
commence à le faire à l'école je crois
qu'on est à deux tiers des départements
qui peuvent aujourd'hui lever
l'obligation du port de masques pour les
enfants on le fait aussi et donc il
s'agit de de quoi il s'agit de dire
qu'il faut qu'on garde les cartes en
main pour pouvoir agir dès lors qu'il y
aurait une reprise épidémique qu'on
garde n'est pas les cartes en main pour
pouvoir agir graduellement et pour
pouvoir par exemple réactiver
immédiatement le pass sanitaires dont je
vous ai dit que j'espérais qu'il sera
levée dès lors que nous pourrons le plus
rapidement possible plutôt que de devoir
attendre que l'épidémie s'aggrave et de
devoir prendre des mesures plus
difficile c'est tout simplement ça c'est
de dire qu'on a des outils qui ont fait
leurs preuves et notamment le pass
sanitaires et qu'on veut les garder dans
la poche pour pouvoir les utiliser si
c'est nécessaire parce qu'aujourd'hui en
l'état actuel du doigt du droit le pas
cette année car ils s'arrêtent au 15
novembre c'est pour ça que nous voulons
prolonger la possibilité de l'utiliser
vous l'avez dit c'est une prolongation
qui enjambe l'élection présidentielle
mais parce que si on avait une reprise
de l'épidémie qui imposait de prendre
des mesures d'abord le fait de devoir
réexaminer un texte rediscuter d'un
extrait élaborer un texte ça prend du
temps et donc par définition ça veut
dire que vous ne pouvez pas mobilisé des
outils immédiatement c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est que chacun
imagine bien je crois que dans un moment
de campagne présidentielle campagne
législative où les députés seront très
probablement en campagne le fait de
reconvoquer le parlement veut les faire
tous revenir à paris pour discuter
pendant plusieurs semaines pourrait être
critiqué par ceux là mêmes qui
critiquent aujourd'hui le fait de
vouloir enjambées l'élection
présidentielle qui nous irons vous
percutez la campagne et c'est donc c'est
tout simplement une décision pragmatique
de vigilance de prudence et de
pragmatisme pour protéger nos
concitoyens je rappelle que cette
échéance du 31 juillet a été validée par
le conseil scientifique dans la vie qui
l'a rendu a été validé par le conseil
d'état qui là aussi nous a rendu un avis
qui a émis plusieurs observations et
notamment une observation sur
l'association du parlement à la gestion
de la crise sanitaire c'est pour ça
qu'on a adapté le texte et que le texte
qui a été adopté en conseil des
ministres voit une disposition
supplémentaires par rapport à l'avant
projet de loi qui avait été transmis au
conseil d'état puisque il prévoit que le
gouvernement devra rendre remettre au
parlement avant le 28 février 2022 un
rapport sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire et sur la nécessité ou non
d'utiliser ou de prolonger des outils de
gestion de la crise sanitaire vous voyez
bien que n'a tenu compte de ses
observations et ensuite y aura un débat
au parlement je pense que chacun pourra
s'exprimer sur ce sujet là et à la fin
c'est évidemment comme depuis le début
de cette crise le parlement qui est
souverain et qui votent la loi je
rappelle que c'est le onzième projet de
loi de gestion de la crise sanitaire qui
est présente et qui va être discuté par
le parlement depuis le début de cette
crise c'est donc aussi une démonstration
que le parlement a été très étroitement
associés à la gestion de cette crise de
manière tout à fait démocratique et
c'est normal depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire
j'ai démarré le coin de france info je
reviens sur le prix et prix à la pompe
la mise de la transition et écologique
barbares pompiers hier annoncé vouloir
convoquer les distributeurs afin de
pouvoir travailler avec eux sur sur la
question des marges
quand est-ce que cette réunion est
prévue si elle est est ce que ça vous
semble le bon levier sachant que ses
marges sont extrêmement faibles et quant
aux mesures sur lesquelles vous
travaillez est-ce que vous travaillez
sur des mesures fiscales type baisse de
la tva ou sur des mesures ciblées
sachant que sur le gaz vous aviez
procéder en deux temps sur la première
question ce n'est pas vous dire la date
exacte de cette réunion qui a annoncé
barbara pompiers hier ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que tous les leviers
doivent être regardées j'entends bien la
question
des marges et c'est tous les leviers
doivent être regardées fait d'avoir une
réunion avec des distributeurs ça permet
au moins de poser les choses de se
parler de regarder quelle est la réalité
ce qui peut être fait par par chacun sur
la deuxième question que vous évoquez
toutes les pistes sont possibles moi je
n'exclus rien par principe ce qui est
important pour nous c'est que la mesure
soit efficace et qu'elle permette
d'accompagner les français qui en ont
besoin encore une fois dans ce moment
difficile on espère et certain nombre
encore une fois d'institutions le disent
et temporaire mais qui pourrait durer
quand même plusieurs mois et donc c'est
pour ça que en avance de phase là aussi
on agit évidemment et qu'on réfléchisse
et qu'on travaille à ces mesures mais
politiquement qu'elle est là quels sont
les classes sociales que vous voulez
atteindre les plus précaires les classes
moyennes tous les français il faut juger
eu l'occasion de rappeler à notre
priorité
évidemment on a une action très forte en
direction des plus précaires mais aussi
en direction des français qui
travaillent qui travaille dur et qui
souvent doivent utiliser leur voiture de
manière incompressibles pour aller
travailler qui donc prennent cette
augmentation d'une dépense qui est une
dépense contrainte pour aller travailler
on a montré aussi avec les mesures qu'on
a prises sur la question l'électricité
et du gaz qu'on pouvait prendre des
mesures qui concernent l'ensemble des
français donc voilà je suis pas d'autres
précisions à vous donner sur la nature
des mesures qui pourraient être prises
ce que je vous dis évidemment c'est
qu'il ya un travail qui est mené pour
ces mesures de protection comme vous
dites si le carburant compte ainsi la
hausse se poursuit se poursuit combien
de temps je vais rester des mesures qui
doivent intervenir rapidement ou pas
jeune femme nommée se poursuit pendant
trois ans au tour suivant contre moi ce
que je vous dis c'est que c'est un sujet
et je vous ai dit d'ailleurs pourquoi
ils ont leur public on avait reparlé ce
matin en conseil des ministres
nous avons une vigilance constante
permanente il y a eu il y aura des
réunions sur ce sujet là encore une fois
pour identifier les mesures qui seraient
les plus efficaces et les plus utiles
pour les français qui sont les plus
impactées
d'agathe londres et ensuite
j'en ai semaine une première question il
ya une procédure qui est engagée par la
préfecture pour fermer la mosquée
d'allonnes suite notamment à des propos
légitimant le recours au djihad armé je
voulais savoir si vous aviez nouveaux
éléments et qu'est-ce que cela dit
surtout du chemin qu'il reste à
parcourir en france aujourd'hui la
mosquée d'allonnes et géré par deux
associations et les informations dont
disposent nos services de renseignement
nous montre qu'on y faisait l'apologie
du djihad de la mort en martyr du
terrorisme et de la haine il y avait
également dans cette mosquée une école
coranique devenue vraisemblablement un
lieu dans les doctrines mans pour une
centaine d'enfants
nous sommes inflexible face à
l'islamisme il nous sommes
intransigeants face à la haine et à la
radicalisation
quand on attaque la république elle doit
répondre il doit répondre fort et donc
nous avons engagé une procédure pour
demander la fermeture de cette mosquée
une procédure que nous avons pu engager
je le rappelle sur le fondement de la
loi sylt la loi sécurité intérieure et
lutte contre le terrorisme qui a été
voté sous ce quinquennat par cette
majorité
une procédure contradictoire est lancé
c'est l'état du droit à une procédure
contradictoire est lancée jusqu'à
mercredi prochain après quoi une
décision sera rendue décision évidemment
que nous attendons en confiance étant
donné le sérieux et la solidité du
dossier dont nous disposons par ailleurs
je vais indiquer que des arrêtés de gel
des avoirs des deux associations et de
certains de leurs dirigeants étaient
pris hier pour couper net toutes les
activités de haine
je veux redire que la loi s'il que
j'évoquais à l'instant nous a donné les
armes pour fermer les lieux de culte où
l'on propage la radicalisation dans
notre pays que notre politique et plus
particulièrement la loi sur le
séparatisme donc considérablement
amplifié que sur 89 lieux de culte
susceptibles d'être radicaliser
d'entraîner à la radicalisation tous ont
été contrôlés un tiers ont été soit
fermées soit suspendu qu'au total plus
de 650 lieux fermés fréquenté par des
fondamentalistes ont été fermés nous
avons au cours de ce mandat 10 ou une
dizaine de structures de culte de
mosquées trois fois plus que sous les
deux mandatures précédentes réunies donc
vous voyez bien que notre main ne
tremble pas dès lors que nous disposons
d'éléments qui nous permettent
d'attester que dans un lieu d'une
manière générale dans un lieu de culte
singulièrement on prêche la
radicalisation la haine de la république
l'apologie du djihad évidemment nous
prenons les mesures qui s'imposent
les français travaillent moins que les
autres a dit le président hier
l'opposition rétorque que c'est faux
chiffres à l'appui et dénonce les
mensonges de chef de l'état et son
mépris aussi que répondez vous à ces
attaques est ce que ce président et un
répondeur raison de dire ça est-ce qu'il
faut travailler davantage en france
selon on trouve ce débat c'est
ahurissant pour deux raisons la première
parce qu'il ya le président de la
république a présenté un plan une
stratégie france 2030 qui vise à
investir de manière colossale pour notre
souveraineté énergétique qui vise à
faire de notre pays le leader de
l'hydrogène vert qui vise à investir
pour une alimentation plus saine qui
vise à investir pour produire plus de
médicaments innovants pour la culture
pour les fonds marins qui vise à
investir de manière colossale pour
retrouver ce temps des conquêtes et
mettre notre pays à la pointe de
l'innovation et vous le disiez les
oppositions donc une chose à la bouche
parce que non je pense pas grand chose à
redire pas grand chose à proposer sur
ces sujets là qui sont quand même des
sujets centraux pour l'avenir de notre
pays et pour les français et qu'ils
tentent de
contester par tous les moyens et de
trouver des polémiques çà c'est la
première raison la deuxième raison c'est
que le président de la république a
rappelé quelque chose qui est factuel et
français travaillent moins en moyenne
que les autres pays de l ocde c'est ce
que disent les statistiques de l' ocde
en 2020 les français avec un emploi a
travaillé près de 300 heures de moins
par an que la moyenne de l'oscd eux si
on part sur des journées de travail de 7
heures c'est plus d'un mois travaillés
en moins et si on regarde le temps de
travail hebdomadaire des personnes avec
un emploi français travaillent deux
heures trente en moins par semaine que
la moyenne des pays de le céder c'est un
constat factuel qui n'enlève rien au
fait que les français travaillent dur
qu'il travaille bien qu'ils sont
d'ailleurs plus productif que beaucoup
de nos voisins mais c'est une réalité
une réalité que le président de la
république a rappelé pour dire que notre
très grande priorité pour rappeler que
nos très grande priorité c'est l'emploi
parce que plus vous avez de français qui
travaillent plus vous avez de
financement pour un modèle de protection
sociale de services publics
d'investissements dans l'éducation dans
l'innovation que nous voulons toutes et
tous garder dans notre pays c'est ça le
sens de l'expression du président de la
république qui encore une fois
s'inscrivaient sur à partir d'un
contexte constat factuel et surtout
s'inscrivait dans le cadre d'un discours
qui prévoit de projeter la france pour
les dix prochaines années dans une
logique d'innovation et
d'investissements massifs
sur le co vite vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure de la difficile montée en
puissance de la campagne de rappel alors
est-ce que vous allez prendre d'autres
mesures des mesures supplémentaires pour
convaincre cette se faire vacciner et
comment allez-vous articuler la
troisième dose avec le pass sanitaires
alors sur le premier point évidemment
qu'on mobilise tous les leviers dont on
dispose notamment tout le travail qui a
été mené avec les collectivités locales
les ccas les associations pour aller
informer les personnes éligibles c'est à
dire aujourd'hui majoritairement les
personnes âgées de plus de 65 ans que
par ailleurs on fait évidemment aussi
confiance aux médecins traitants aux
pharmaciens aux professionnels de santé
qui au contact de leurs patients peuvent
leur rappeler l'importance de procéder à
ce rappel vaccinal encore une fois pour
que l'immunité conférée par la
vaccination reste très élevé et donc on
va poursuivre cette mobilisation il ya
des mesures supplémentaires qui sont
prises aujourd'hui même nous lançons une
nouvelle campagne de communication grand
public pour insister sur la nécessité
d'avoir recours au rappel vaccinal sur
la deuxième question que vous avez posé
aujourd'hui la troisième dose ou le
rappel vaccinal n'est pas requis dans le
cadre du pass sanitaire de votre
question sur l'arctique alisation ça
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
bonjour amusé comme de bloomberg alors
pardonnez moi d'insister mais avec les
prix de l'essence mais est ce qu'une
décision peut venir ou une annonce dans
les jours à venir dans les semaines à
venir ou dans les mois à venir face au
plus elles intentionnés plus précis et
une deuxième question sur sur le break
cité la pêche le gouvernement français a
dit que des mesures de rétorsion contre
le royaume uni allait être prise dans la
deuxième quinzaine d'octobre
il me semble que vous avez dit mes
confrères moi j'étais pas là mais la
semaine dernière que vous viendriez vers
nous aujourd'hui pour nous indiquer ce
qu'il en était voilà où est ce qu'on en
est sur le premier point je crois avoir
montré dans mon intervention est dans la
réponse aux différentes questions
d'abord que c'est un sujet qu'on suit de
très près et un travail nourri qui est
menée ensuite que sur la question du gaz
et l'électricité on a pris des mesures
très tôt en avance de phase et on n'a
pas hésité à prendre ces mesures
évidemment qu'on les prendra le moment
venu ensuite sur la deuxième question
moi je veux rappeler que la ligne qui
est aujourd'hui suivie par les autorités
britanniques est inadmissible et
inacceptable parce qu'elle ne respecte
pas l'accord qui a été signé dans le
cadre du brics dit que de notre côté la
france on a toujours produit toutes les
demandes qui était fait on a toujours
répondu à toutes les demandes n'a
toujours produit tous les documents qui
était demandé nos pêcheurs les
organisations professionnelles de
pêcheurs ont été absolument admirable
extrêmement patient parce qu'évidemment
cette situation c'est un motif d'
angoisse colossal pour nos pêcheurs qui
veulent tout simplement pouvoir
continuer à travailler donc on a
toujours été au rendez-vous en
respectant fidèlement l'accord qui a été
signé et on constate aujourd'hui qui est
volonté
manifestement à ce stade de ne pas
respecter l'accord donc qu'est ce qui a
été fait et qu'est ce qui va être fait
ce qui a été fait d'abord c'est la
demande de réunion de ce qu'on appelle
le conseil de partenariat au niveau
européen avec les britanniques pour
faire le point sur ce sujet là et voir
les suites qui peuvent être données au
niveau européen qu'est ce qui va être
fait ce vendredi même la ministre de la
mère annick girardin rencontrera le vice
président de la commission européenne
sur ce sujet et elle sera accompagnée
des organisations professionnelles de
pêcheurs pour échanger avec le vice
président de la commission européenne et
pour là aussi mobiliser encore davantage
l'union européenne sur ce sujet là mais
elle est évidemment mobilisé mais vous
savez que c'est par l'entremise de
l'union européenne que ce fonds à ces
discussions et que se prennent les
décisions ce que pouvons faire aussi
c'est des mesures de rétorsion qui
peuvent être prises par la france sur ce
sujet là le président de la république
et premiers ministres ont demandé au
gouvernement de travailler à des mesures
et un travail qui a été mené on voit
aujourd'hui des différentes mesures qui
pourrait être actionné si nous
constations qu'il y avait cette volonté
manifeste est maintenue de ne pas
respecter l'accord et en tout état de
cause ces mesures pourraient être
annoncées active et à la fin la semaine
prochaine pour se conformer au délai que
vous avez évoqué puisque je crois que
c'est jusqu'à la fin du mois d'octobre
que les autorités britanniques peuvent
transmettre les licences mais évidemment
nous travaillons en avance de phase pour
être en capacité de réagir dès lors que
cette position serait maintenu
sylvie corbet associative presse est ce
que vous pouvez apporter des précisions
sur l'hommage qui sera rendu à samuel
pâti dans les écoles ce vendredi
notamment à ce que toutes les écoles
collèges et lycées vont organiser une
minute de silence et le cas échéant un
échange avec les élèves
nous commémorons en cette fin de semaine
mais un nom de l'assassinât terrible
tragique de samuel pâtit et cet attentat
terroriste perpétré sur notre sol
je vais évidemment à nouveau rendre
hommage à sa mémoire il y aura
évidemment un hommage dans notre pays en
fin de semaine d'abord vendredi vous
l'avez dit un hommage dans nos
établissements scolaires c'est à dire
que dans tous les établissements
scolaires il y aura une minute de
silence il y aura une heure de cours qui
donnera lieu à un échange autour de la
mémoire de samuel pâtit nous avons
produit des ressources pédagogiques pour
les équipes pédagogiques qui sont
disponibles sur une plate forme qu'on
appelle eduscol et nous laissons
évidemment les équipes pédagogiques
décider de la manière dont elles veulent
organiser cet échange ensuite samedi il
y aura un hommage plus institutionnelle
avec le dévoilement d'une plaque au
ministère de l'éducation nationale et la
famille de samuel pâtir rencontrera le
premier ministre puis le président de la
république samedi
une dernière question concernant des
propos tenus lors d'un conseil municipal
à la mairie de cachan un élu la france
insoumise ou s'interrogeaient sur
l'équipement des policiers municipaux en
armes
nelu cet élu aurait dit le but de la
police est de protéger la population il
n'est pas de posséder des armes pour la
tuer des propos qui ont choqué lors de
ce conseil municipal est ce que les
condamnés qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
mation vous m'apprenez ses propos moi
j'ai l'habitude de m'exprimer sur des
propos que j'ai pu me renvoie
recontextualiser mais je vais vous dire
le pire c'est que je suis pas très
surpris parce que malheureusement on a
eu l'habitude de voir dans une partie de
la gauche
cette dérive terrible d'assimiler nous
policiers et policières nos gendarmes à
des tueurs à des personnes qui
voudraient faire du mal délibérément qui
s'attaquerait aux français et c'est
alors que ce qu'ils font de manière
admirable au quotidien c'est protéger
nos concitoyens donc évidemment comme je
le fais à chaque fois évidemment que je
condamne ce type de propos je pense que
les français aussi dans leur très grande
majorité
bien s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions
je vous dis
à la semaine prochaine